are we running concentration camps at
our border that's what Alexandra okay so
Cortez claims and we'll take a look at
that claim that rather a stupid claim
here in a moment but first I want to
tell you about big token big token is a
new app it's pretty cool I want you to
you should check this out because it's a
new app that lets you share data about
yourself your interest your habits and
then get paid for it the getting paid
for it is the highlight here because
right now you already share a lot of ton
of information with tech companies and
they're the ones who make money off of
it so what about you this is your
information you should be getting paid
that's what big token comes in here's
how it works first you download the app
you sign up for a free big token account
have done it myself very easy to do they
walk you through the process take just a
couple minutes next you complete actions
to earn points so actions include
answering surveys checking into
locations connecting your social
accounts and more and then you can
redeem your points for rewards just as
such as cash or gift cards or you could
donate your earnings to charity if
you're a very generous person you choose
what data you share with big token and
then you get paid for it the surveys in
the app will ask general questions about
your demographics and lifestyle
there are also surveys around specific
holidays and events all that kind of
stuff you know the point here is that
your it's your data you have a right to
it
if anyone's making money off of it it
should be you and I think that's that's
that's that's the point your data is
always secure with Big Talk it based on
the data you choose to share you'll be
placed into specific ad groups and
brands will buy access to those ad
groups for use in personal advertising
and then you get paid again to highlight
that point if you want to start earning
money for your data go to the App Store
or Google Play search for big token
b.i.g Tok en that's one word download
the app and sign up make sure to use my
referral code that's Matt Walsh again
search big token in the App Store or
Google Play
download the app use my referral code
matt walsh to sign up claim your data
and get paid okay
now let's try to get ourselves caught up
to speed on this our friend Alexandria
Carroll Cortez was doing one of her
iconic Instagram live performances where
she just rambles incoherently about
whatever subject happens to pop into her
head and in the course of that of that
spectacle
she made a rather startling claim listen
listen to this the United States is
running concentration camps and that is
exactly what they are they are
concentration camps and if that doesn't
bother you I don't I like we can have
okay whatever I want to talk to the
people that are concerned enough with
humanity to say that we should not that
never again means something and that the
fact that concentration camps are now in
institutionalized practice in the home
of the free is extraordinarily
disturbing ok now this isn't really the
point but personally my favorite part of
that clip I thought the the part where
she is the most eloquent is is this part
right here if that doesn't bother you
I don't I like we can have okay whatever
I'm gonna talk to the people very
profound
profoundly eloquent she truly is the
voice of her generation but more to the
point I suppose she says that we are
sending immigrants to concentration
camps and she says never again
concentration camps never again now any
reasonable person hears that an
immediate immediate Lee knows that it is
a Holocaust reference Jews were sent to
concentration camps and never again has
been the mantra among the Jewish people
and among all people the world over
saying
we're never gonna have another Holocaust
right that's that's everybody knows that
you say concentration camps and never
again you are evoking the Holocaust
period very clearly but of course it's
inappropriate and absurd and hyperbolic
and manipulative and exploitative and
and and any other words you could think
of to compare immigrant detention
centers to Nazi death camps so people
react to day Oasys remarks negatively
they're very critical of it and aoc true
to form being the brave warrior for
truth that she is responded by lying and
claiming that she was not referencing
the Holocaust and that's not what she
meant and just because you're talking
about concentration camps doesn't mean
you're necessarily talking about the
Holocaust which is technically true
right I mean you can have if you want to
look up the dictionary definition of
concentration camp it's not gonna say a
Nazi death camp technically there are
other concentration camps and and it
doesn't necessarily refer to that but
when you throw in never again it's
pretty clear the the comparison your
tried to make aoc followed up with a
tweet saying and for the shrieking
Republicans who don't know the
difference concentration camps are not
the same as death camps concentration
camps are considered by experts as the
massed attention of civilians without
trial and that's exactly what this
administration is doing it's kind of
funny to heat the hear AOC accuse anyone
else of shrieking considering she's the
most streaky politician in Washington
right now but never mind that
now in one of the weirdest displays I
think I've ever seen
left is spent the day on social media
yesterday trying to parse sort of the
difference between concentration camp
and Nazi death camp claiming that AOC
was talking about concentration camps
which are just places for the detention
of people without a trial and not Nazi
death camps but this is obviously
ludicrous for a number of reasons first
of all
everyone knows as I said everyone knows
what comes to mind forget about
dictionary definitions for a minute when
you say concentration camp if we're
playing a word association game and I
say concentration camp you're gonna say
Holocaust or Nazi or Hitler that's
that's why people that's the associate
association we all make and that's
precisely why people use the phrase
concentration camp in a context like
this because they're trying to evoke
that imagery and the emotions that are
associated with it that's why she used
the term because of those associations
second as I said she said never again
that's an explicit Holocaust reference
third if concentration camps are just
places where people are detained without
a trial then the county jail is a
concentration camp right the drunk tank
is a concentration camp security at the
airport is a concentration camp we've
really made the term into something
ambiguous and innocuous which is not
what the left wants to do they want to
they want the term to retain the
Holocaust associations and they want you
to believe that there is a holocaust
happening down at the border that's
their point it's just that when they get
called on it they look for a back exit
because they know they can't possibly
offer any rational defense for the claim
that we're running you know Nazi we're
doing a Nazi like operation down on the
border so here's the real question
putting all that to the side however you
characterize these detainment centers
which is what they are and I think
that's the most straightforward way of
describing them they are centers of
detainment places where we detain people
so however you characterize it if you
don't like that if you don't like what
we're doing what should we be doing in
your mind as it stay
right now we have detention centers or
detainment centers that are used because
there's a flood of people coming across
the border some are sneaking across some
are claiming asylum well we can't just
let them all waltz into the country and
then go about their merry way and
backing up for a second this is another
difference between what we've got going
on and a concentration camp because
people people are choosing to come here
knowing what's going to happen knowing
that there's that there are detainment
centers and that's where they can end up
maybe people come here this is their
choice generally a concentration camp is
is well-liked within Nazi Germany the
Germans went in and they rounded up not
they rounded up people they rounded up
their political enemies they rounded up
Jews and and anyone else that they
wanted to kill or get rid of they
rousted them out of their home and they
put them on train cars or buses and they
brought them to these camps that's not
what's happening here these are people
who come to us their own choice they
don't have to come they could turn
around and go home anytime they want do
you think people in concentration camps
have the option to just say yeah you
know what never mind I'll go home if you
have that option you're not in a
concentration camp
so again what's the other option
and even
someone's applying for asylum while
those claims need to be processed and
investigated and during that period
before the Asylum is approved or not
approved what do we do with the asylum
seeker we can't send them home because
because that's where they're trying to
get asylum from right they're trying
they're trying to leave their home okay
so they don't want to go home we can't
just let them go because then we'll
never see or hear from them again and
then there's no point of the asylum
process because they'll get a de facto
asylum just by disappearing into the
interior of the country so what's what
option do we have we have to detain them
while we process the claims or if
they're sneaking across then we detain
them while we get ready to send them
back and how do we detain them a lot is
made over the separation of families at
the border but we don't have the
facilities to give entire families their
own little homes their own little
cottages to live in while we sort
everything out and as a matter of safety
you don't want to throw a bunch of kids
in to the same detainment facilities as
as you know as a bunch of unknown grown
men we also don't even know if the kids
who are coming across with with the
adults really belong to those adults
they don't always there's a lot of human
trafficking and stuff that happens at
the border as well so there are a lot of
complications and that's how families
end up getting separated is it nice
is it pretty I guess not but I honestly
don't know what the alternative is I've
never heard anyone suggest an
alternative I've heard a lot of people
complain about the situation as it
stands right now but I've never heard a
better suggestion I've never heard
someone say okay here's what we can do
instead because as I said just letting
them go that is not a plan that's not a
strategy but I've never heard a plan
if your issue is just with the
conditions of the camp's if you claim
that the conditions are not up to snuff
then okay then complain about that call
for better conditions but AO C and the
other leftist they seem to be taking
issue with the with the whole practice
of detainment itself yet again they
don't offer a better solution it's like
I mean think about actual prisons now
the stuff we got going on down at the
border those aren't prisons but but as a
different example if you think about
prisons the whole idea of a prison is
kind of grim and ugly and and not ideal
right I mean in an ideal scenario you
wouldn't have any prisons because you
wouldn't have any need for them you're
locking people in cages not letting them
go outside except for brief stretches
and they're you know they've got people
men with guns trained on them at all
times it's not a fun thing but but but
what's the other option I mean it's very
easy to walk into a prison as is
horrible but you got all these people
locked up and chained up and this is a
terrible okay yeah it is kind of
horrible but what's what choice do we
have
just let the murderers go free make them
promise not to do it again yeah that's
not gonna work you see when someone goes
and commits a serious crime they put us
as a society in a lose-lose situation
because we don't want to have prisons
we'd prefer not to have them
no one has prisons are not fun things
but we also can't let this person go
because they're a danger to society so
they're the ones they create a lose-lose
situation where there is no great option
and you just have to make do and deal
with the situation and that's what they
they're the ones who do that by
committing the crime it's the same thing
on the border when people flood across
the border into our country even if they
aren't murderers or whatever else the
fact is they are creating a situation
where there just isn't any perfect or
even very pretty way of handling it
they're doing that so we can only handle
it the best we can
we should always respect their dignity
as human beings because we should
respect everyone's
dignity as a human being but we also
have to enforce our laws we have to do
our due diligence and we have to process
claims when the claims are made we have
to do all that stuff it's really easy to
complain about this but suggesting
solutions is a different matter and and
by the way I'm not dogmatic on
immigration personally I'm not one of
these people who thinks that you know
every single illegal in the country
right now should be rounded up and
deported regardless of circumstance we
need to build an 80-foot wall across the
entire border like the Great Wall of
China I'm you know I'm not I'm not that
hardline I mean I'm I do believe in
protecting the border and enforcing our
immigration laws don't get me wrong but
I'm open to any and all solutions
personally I'm willing to have that
discussion but the problem is that left
is for the most part don't have any
ideas they don't have any Salette don't
offer anything they don't bring anything
to the table they just complain and you
know they they come basically their
argument with immigration much like
their argument with with with many other
issues is essentially just to sing the
John Lennon's song imagine they'll
imagine there is no war imagine there
were no countries imagine there's no
violence imagine they just just at all
it's just terrible trite stupid song
that is very little redeeming about it
but that's alright but that's not an
argument it's like yeah we could imagine
that that'd be great
McGann it would be great if we didn't
need detainment centers it would be
great if the whole world could live in
harmony with one another holding hands
and singing Kumbaya and all that I mean
that would be fantastic but it's not the
reality that we live in and so we need
to the reality is that we live in a
world with countries countries that are
not all the same and often don't get
along and so we need borders and it just
so happens that the country to the south
of us in fact that whole region to the
south of us is not in good shape
and there are a lot of there's a there's
a lot of chaos and anarchy and drug
cartels and violence and human
trafficking and all this stuff and so we
have to be very careful about who we let
through and then when you end up with
floods of people trying to barge their
way in we've got to take them detain
them and figure figure it out not ideal
but that's the way it is all right what
else let's see here
well three female athletes in
Connecticut are I just want to mention
this briefly because in Connecticut
these three female athletes are filing a
discrimination complaint against the
policy in the state that allows
biological males to compete against
girls which is something we've talked
about many times up there in Connecticut
and they're saying that this robs them
of metals and that they should have won
and it's discriminatory and they're
against it and they're completely right
of course that's completely accurate
there just is the case that they make it
III mean thank God that this is
happening I've been waiting for for
someone to step up and file a complaint
like this and to force those who support
the idea of putting this crazy insane
idea of setting putting biological males
in female sports those people should be
forced to go to court and defend that
idea because it is indefensible the case
that these girls are making is a
rock-solid indisputable case there is no
argument against them as I've said
plenty of times in the past I have never
heard this this is the fascinating thing
about this subject is that even though
you have these these laws now across the
country and you find this increasingly
the situation where boys are put in with
girls and sports because they claim to
be girls even though this is happening
and it's so common now I have never
heard a good argument for it it's kind
of like the immigration thing I've never
heard anyone suggest an alternative well
for this I've never even
really hurt anyone even tried to defend
it I don't even know what did what what
the argument in defense is I've never
heard one aside from just well these
boys say they're girls and it would hurt
their feelings if they came that's not
an argument that's not even close to an
argument and because we can we can just
get rid of it immediately by saying yes
but then all these other girls who now
can't win because the boys their
feelings are hurt and so you've got a
lot more hurt feelings on the girls side
so that's not good enough
you've got hurt feelings first hurt
feelings and there are a lot more hurt
feelings on the one side so that
outweighs it you got you got to come
with something else you get because then
your next argument has to be well yeah
but the boys you see their feelings
matter more that must be your argument
and that again that's not an argument
that's just nonsense
there is simply no good reason to allow
this and there are a lot of good reasons
not to so I'm very glad that we're
seeing this alright let's see here's
something else that we we talked about
this last week and we we talked last
week about the sexual ization of
children right that is going on
especially by leftist their agenda to
sexualize children to normalize
pedophilia and this is a theme that i
talk about frequently something i've
been warning about for years i didn't
plan to bring it up again this week but
i saw this article in The Huffington
Post and I just can't ignore it I I have
to tell you about it because it's so I
mean I wish I had noticed this last week
when I was talking about this because
this is this is Exhibit A right here
okay
here's an article in The Huffington Post
allegedly a prominent and respected
publication the headline is our pride
parades kid friendly parents say
children can handle the kink children
can handle the kink that is that that is
a sentence written in the headline of an
article and I've imposed children can
handle the kink now if you ever find
yourself making that argument if you
ever find yourself in a situation where
you are sincerely making the argument
that children can handle the kink that
here's what you need to do you need to
go to NASA and you need to ask if you
can board one of their rockets and then
ask them to shoot you directly to the
moon you need to deport yourself I don't
know if it works that way down it now
I'm not sure if they'll but at least try
I mean this is what you you need to get
to the nearest rocket ship and just
deport yourself to the moon or really
any by any any heavenly body that is not
the earth because you don't even belong
on planet earth if that's if that's your
you just there's no place for you here
I'm afraid let's read a little bit from
this article it says each year in the
blaze written by Briana sharp by the way
Branagh sharp is the one who thinks that
children can handle the king car well
she says parents say that children can
handle the kick each year in the blaze
and if you're a parent arguing that your
own children can quote handle the kink
then you just need to go to prison
because you're an abusive disgusting
horrible parent and your children are in
danger because of you each year in the
Blazing Sun of the Pride Parade and
Nelson I guess this isn't Kenna
pegye I don't know that pegye Wren is
the name here and her two young
grandkids seek shade under the spinning
rainbow Paracels ran a semi a
semi-retired sex therapist told HuffPost
canada the Paracels were a magical find
and have come to symbolize the
importance of this event for her family
blah blah blah blah blah she says I
can't imagine a safer place for families
to bring children but then the article
goes on to say anyone who has been to a
parade has likely seen the procession
of leather animal costumes kinky
costumes in every hue and more skin than
is normally exposed in public now it's
interesting to hear them finally
admitting this because usually when you
accuse pride parades of being overly
sexualized Affairs where there's people
dressed up in bondage gear and stuff
like that because that's what she's
talking about usually when you say that
they'll deny it and say what are you
talking about you're crazy it's just a
pride brain people are just coming out
and kids are there they're waving flags
it's just it's it's just you know it's
no different than any other parade it's
perfectly family-friendly but here they
are admitting that yeah well there's
more skin than what you'll normally see
and yeah there are people dressed up in
bondage gear but or dressed up you know
in leather animal cut let's be clear
about what that means by the way leather
animal costumes and other kinky costumes
quote unquote so those are people who
have a sexual fetish for pretending to
be an animal and then they engage in
sexual exploits with people who have
fetishes of copulating with animals I
mean that's that's what that means
that's your fetishes to pretend to be an
animal and you're with someone who likes
to be with people who pretend to be
animals I mean this is this is sick
gross stuff that no person should be
exposed to let alone kids and then it
goes on to talk I'm not gonna write
actually I can't I was my plan was to
read from this article I can't do it
because it's
- disgusting but suffice it to say that
they they go on to justify having kids
they're saying the kids can handle it
writer educator and publisher s Behr
Bergman told The Huffington Post Canada
there's absolutely no reason not to take
our kids to pride it's a fun day there
are a lot of bubbles rainbow streamers
and enjoyable performances and bondage
gear it's there right as queer spawn and
as a parent I might want to take my kids
to pride because they might be lesbian
gay bi trans queer or two-spirit queer
spawn that's when you call your kids
what in God's name there's a line here
at the very end that I need to I just
need to read then it will just be done
with this if I can find it so here it is
Bergman says first of all nobody likes
nakedness more than children and we're
just gonna you know what I'll just I'll
just I'll cut it off right there because
that's the argument that this Bergman is
making about the quote queer spawn he's
saying that well children you know
children love being naked children the
no one no one loves nakedness more than
children no one loves nakedness more
than children children can handle the
kink okay these are the arguments being
presented these are the arguments made
by pedophiles
these are pedophilic arguments these are
arguments for pedophilia I mean it's
right there in front of our face they're
not even trying to hide it anymore guys
they're being very explicit about it
you've not yet you've now got gay
activists I'd yeah sure you got bondage
gear and all that kind of crap at the
bribe oh yeah bring the kids as a they
they love making this and they can
handle the kink that's an art that is a
pedophile argument
so when I say that the left wants to
normalize pedophilia I'm not
exaggerating this is not fear-mongering
this is not a conspiracy theory this is
just literally what they're doing I'm
just telling you what they're doing and
we have to decide if we want to put up
with that or not let's see one other one
other thing I wanted to mention there's
an article in Time Time magazine that I
found interesting the headline headline
is we tell our kids that hard work
always pays off what happens when they
fail anyway and I was ready I saw this
article online and I was I was ready to
laugh at the article when I first
started reading it because it sounds
like the typical you know oh the poor
kids what happens when they start to
fail well you know you tell them get
back on the horse and try again right I
mean pretty simple but the point that
the article makes article written by by
Rachel Simmons it makes the point that
we we stuff a lot of positive mindset
propaganda into our kids heads we tell
them they can achieve anything if they
work hard enough we tell them that
positive attitude and hard work can
accomplish any goal we tell them that
they can do whatever they set their
minds to and so on they can be whatever
they want to be when in reality that
isn't true right now the author Simmons
gets into a lot of identity politics
stuff talking about minority students
students and discrimination and bringing
like that sort of thing into it but
which things that I think are irrelevant
to this issue because this is not a rate
she makes it into kind of a racial thing
I don't think it's a racial thing at all
but if we can put the SJW stuff to the
side the central thesis is correct it
important that people actually cannot
achieve anything they put their mind to
sometimes you you can really try very
hard and still discover that you just
don't have what it takes to do whatever
you're trying to do I mean you can give
it your all practice makes perfect
blah blah blah and at the end of the day
discover
that you're still not good enough I that
does happen it happens everyone I mean
the average person could practice day
and night from the age of four and still
by the age of 19 or 20 not be nearly
good enough for the NBA because only a
very small fraction of all basketball
players will ever make it to the NBA and
those are the people ever in the NBA
right if you make the NBA all those
people worked hard they all are hard
workers they've all been practicing
since the moment they could walk they're
all determined they all have ambition
they've all got that but the ones in the
NBA they also just have natural skill
and ability and talent they they have
something else that even if you practice
as much as them you might never have or
you could put all your heart and soul
into math and science and never get a
job as a NASA engineer you could try
really hard to be a writer and still
never write anything that's any good I
see that sometimes with people people
will send me emails you know asking how
I got into writing and working in media
and doing whatever it is I do I don't
even know what I do but sometimes people
will ask sending emails or how did you
get into that and they'll tell me if
they want to get into a two and they'll
send me links to the blog that they've
been updating every day for the last
five years and the YouTube channel
they've been vlogging on every day since
2016 and they'll show me all the hard
work and effort they put in a day that
you tele did they've been working at
this hard for a long time and which is
admirable but sometimes I'll look at it
and it's very clear to me that it's just
not good unfortunately it's there
they're just not good at this and even
after all that time they're still just
not good at it and so they're not ever
going to be successful doing it because
they're not good enough and that that's
also an important reality that our kids
need to understand it is
able to simply be not good enough for
something because you're not going to be
good at everything and sometimes what
you want to do doesn't match up with
what you can do and that is a really
important lesson the way to be
successful at anything in my mind is is
to be undeniable it's not just to work
hard it's to be undeniable to be so good
that you cannot be denied that you will
absolutely get a spot on the team will
get the job grow the audience whatever
it is you're trying to do you're
undeniable you cannot be denying you are
so good at it
you are you are you're better than most
everyone else trying to do it that's how
you succeed be undeniable that's the key
to success but hard work is not the only
ingredient necessary and being
undeniable you also need skill you need
talent you need a certain Flair for
whatever it is you're trying to do you
need to be good in essence and what if
you aren't good what if what if you'll
never be good at the thing you're trying
to do what a certain point need to
realize when to move on I think it's
kind of like you know I like to fish I'm
a I'm a I'm a big fan of fishing and it
this is a mistake you can make as a
fisherman or or as an angler is the
politically correct term to use as an
angler a mistake you can make is it's
almost there is a mistake in fishing
where you could have too much patience
like if you want to if you want to fish
you have to have patience but you can
also have too much patience because you
could you could find a great spot you've
got shade you know you're on the water
you find a great spot there's shade
there's structure in the water there's
tree stumps there's maybe an old
broken-down dock or something for the
fish died under there's cover there's
weeds and stuff there's a there's a
steep ledge which goes into the deeper
water so the fish can come up it's a
wonderful spot you see bait fish around
great spot that's where you should be
able to catch fish but you cast the lure
out you don't get any bites you cast
again you don't get it by you casting on
you don't get a bite and then for you
stay there for like an hour or two and
you never get a bite
that's a mistake you stayed too long
because even though everything was right
you had all the ingredients you did you
did everything right but it's just not
working it's just not happy it should
it's just not happening for you and so
you need to know when to cut your losses
and just go find a different spot
because there's a spot there the fish
are somewhere you will find them there's
someone on the lake you just gotta find
them and I think it's the same thing
it's kind of a same lesson we need to
teach our kids which is it's important
to try hard it's important to put in the
effort it's important to do things the
right way those are the ingredients but
sometimes even if you have all those
ingredients the spot you chose the thing
you're trying to do just isn't right for
you and you got to go find a different
spot and you need to know when to do
that when to switch things up think
about all those you know reality talent
shows where they you know the high
people come on there are some people who
are really good and then you always have
those people who the only reason they
made it on the show is because they're
terrible at what they're trying to do
and so then we all can laugh at how bad
they are which i think is kind of cruel
and awful honestly but well you find
these town whatever singing competitions
or talent shows you find these people
that get up there and they're on TV and
they're trying out and they're awful and
then they get shut down by the judges
and they start crying and they sigh but
I've been working at this since I was
three years old and I'm not gonna give
up when really know someone should have
sat them down long ago and said no give
up on this don't give up on life but
just give up on this you're not a good
singer you never will be
give up do something else find something
else I think if you if you if we never
are willing to say that to someone then
we set them up for a lifetime of failure
and that's something that it this is
where the schools should come in if
we're sending kids to schools for you
know seven hours a day nine months a
year for twelve or thirteen years the
school should help them figure out not
just what they want to do but what
they're good at what their skills are
what their aptitude where their aptitude
lies but unfortunately the schools are
not doing that and so you've got a lot
of kids who graduate have no idea what
they're good at or where their skills
are and so they're just kind of deciding
randomly what they want to do even if
they have no aptitude in that area
whatsoever
so I think that's something that the
school should be doing as well all right
um I think we'll leave it there thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed president Trump kicks
off his bid to make America great again
again we will examine what the 2020
campaign looks like then Americans
celebrate the end of slavery and the
left goes so woke it is now rejecting
Woody Guthrie check it all out on the
Michael Noel's show